We're ASIAN KUNG-FU GENERATION,
thank you for having us.
Thank you.
"Please introduce yourselves."
"Tell us about how you decided on the band's
name, as well as how you came to form a band."
I'm Kita, ASIAN KUNG-FU
GENERATION's guitarist.
Nice to meet you.
I'm Gotoh, on guitar and vocal.
I'm Yamada on bass.
I'm Ijichi on drums.
How we decided on the name and
how we came to be a band...
I came up with the name of the
band before we formed the band.
On your own.
It was the name I wanted
to use if I had a band.
I loved listening to
Western music back then.
And I had this big dream,
almost a delusion of grandeur,
which was to play music overseas,
outside of Japan someday.
So as a proof of our identity,
I felt it might be a good idea to
include "Asian" in the band name.
As for "Kung-fu", I was really into kung-fu
films by stars like Jackie Chan and Bruce Lee,
so I wanted to have "kung-fu" in the name.
As for "Generation", that just sounded cool,
so I just threw it in there at the end.
A nice ring to it.
Right, when we formed the band, the
name had already been decided.
Right.
Two of us got together first.
Kita-kun was waiting for me in the
courtyard of the college at night.
The day before, I was talking
to him at the school music club
about maybe starting up our own band.
And the next day, he came out of the
darkness in the college courtyard and said,
"You said you wanted to
start a band yesterday..."
That was his love call.
And I said yes.
I never thought it would last
this long at that time.
But he was a bit like a stalker, how
he was waiting for me at night.
I guess it was evening, the dim-lit evening.
I was taking evening
classes at college, so...
That was scary. Then we invited Yama-chan.
Yes.
Kiyoshi was in the same club.
And three years later,
the four of us became a band.
"It's been 25 years since
the band was formed.
What kind of efforts do you make
to cater to both the fans who have
followed you since the
beginning and new fans?"
I think we try not to rank and
differentiate fans that way.
By that, I mean the fans
who have been supporting us
for a long time and the fans
who have just discovered us...
How should I put it? There is no difference.
As long as they like the music
we're playing right now...
Regardless of the timing, we welcome
anyone who likes our music.
Through our concerts,
live sessions, or on screen,
if you like the feelings
and sounds of our music,
we kind of see you as a part of our group.
So I think not judging the
fans based on how long
they've been following us is
the answer to this question.
That's what I think.
"Your music has the influence
from many genres of music,
such as 90's alternative
rock, indie rock, and pop-punk.
What is your favorite genre of music? Is
there a genre that you'd like to try out?"
I bet we're all different.
Let's start with Kiyoshi.
What is your favorite music genre, and
is there a genre you'd like to try?
I've always loved metal.
Oh, you like metal.
That's how I started playing in a band.
And then I joined AKG, and only recently
I started to like guitar rock.
In the future, I kind of want to
try out something like dance rock.
That's a sudden confession. Dance rock?
We have to talk it through.
How about you, Yama-chan?
Well, when I listen to music that is being
streamed, I tend to choose alternative rock.
90's alternative rock is
something I listened to a lot
since that's when I started
to get into music.
So I go back to that often.
And you?
Favorite genre for me?
Right now, I find rap music
interesting to listen to,
seeing what kind of beat
is popular right now.
Or Latin music.
I listen to a variety of music.
Multinational music?
Yeah, I have a bunch of genres that I love.
I like Japanese traditional folk music too.
What I want to try...
It's up to a discussion with the members,
so I can't proclaim here that I want
to try dance rock, for example...
Right. For me, I'd say... my favorite
playlist tends to be indie rock as well.
You do like that stuff.
I think I tend to listen to a lot of U.S. indie rock.
And what I'm interested in trying out is...
Like Kiyoshi mentioned dance rock,
a part of me thinks I want to try
what my band members want to try.
I'm also on the lookout for
what I want to do though...
That's where I'm at.
"From Summer Sonic, to Fuji Rock, Weezer
Fes, and Nano Mugen Fes that you host,
you've been performing at
a lot of live concerts.
What do live concerts mean for
your overall music career?"
We create music and songs,
and we release it.
Then we start talking about numbers,
like how much it sold where,
where it is on the chart, or how much
it's downloaded in which country.
But it makes us anxious because we
can't really see the fans' faces.
Like, we don't know who these people are.
Even if we hear such numbers...
Exactly. But when we perform live, we see them
right there, like when we performed in Brazil.
I don't know if we'll ever
get to visit Fortaleza again,
but we got to see people who were
waiting for us to come and perform.
Seeing that in real life is really...
It gives us energy to create.
So, the fans may come to our
concerts, wanting to see us.
But for us, it's like where
we get our energy from,
as well as the place where we get
to witness our trusted fans.
So it's special.
It makes me feel alive.
Honestly we were moved, to go and
perform in Latin America.
Yes, we are moved wherever
we go, like Asian countries.
We know that our fans are in Asia too
through Facebook and such.
Yeah, like getting emails from them.
But seeing them from the stage was amazing.
Like, "they really do exist..."
It was moving.
They sang along too, which made me happy.
Like, "they really do exist..."
"What is your favorite tour? Do you have
a plan to tour overseas in the future?"
Do you have a favorite tour?
Kiyoshi, how about you?
A favorite tour...
On the very first European tour of four
countries or so, we went to London.
And that view of London left
a strong impression on me.
And there were so many fans in Paris.
Yeah.
That took us by surprise.
In 2015, if I remember correctly,
we toured Europe and then went to
South America for like two weeks.
I remember that tour very well.
True.
And we got to do a North and South
American tour two years later.
There are so many memories,
and it was all great.
Performing overseas is one of
the motivations for our band.
So we can tour internationally again.
It motivates us to create songs too.
"From Naruto, BLEACH, Fullmetal
Alchemist to The Tatami Galaxy,
you have created many hit songs that are
widely loved by many international anime fans.
You're pioneers of the
anime OP/ED composers who had
a huge impact on international anime fans.
Did you expect that you would have this many
international fans when you were creating these songs?"
Back when we made them?
When we made "Haruka Kanata,"
the theme song for Naruto,
I remember speaking with a SONY director,
and how we talked about the fact
that we got to do the OP for
this show was so meaningful,
and we could be on the world
stage with this anime.
It's an anime about ninja, and I thought
it was very Japanese and interesting.
So I knew it would be popular overseas,
but I never expected this much.
No matter where we go, Naruto
feels like it's on another level,
with how loved and watched the
show is, all over the world.
Even to this day.
Exactly. I'm reminded of how
great of an anime that was.
It's a fun show.
And recently, when we're asked to
create songs for anime like that,
we already have international
fans in mind to some extent.
That's true.
It does affect how we create music.
When we made the song for Naruto, it was
almost like... how should I put it...
Ninja-like?
Right, Ninja-like. Something the
four of us have in common.
We wanted to choose something a
bit more oriental in scale.
Also in phrasing.
We wanted to choose something a
bit more oriental in scale.
Like how YMO did so in the past.
We thought that a slightly distorted
Japanese melody might work better,
and it was reflected in
the guitar riff and such.
And it's nice to hear the
fans sing along in concerts.
Makes me happy.
So it does affect our music.
Absolutely.
"Did you watch Bocchi the Rock! ?
Every episode title is
named after your songs,
and the characters' names
also come from your names.
Are you involved in the
manga or the anime series?"
We didn't really...
We didn't actively approach them.
But it made me really happy,
as well as surprised.
It's already very popular overseas.
That's true.
There are scenes of Kanazawa Hakkei,
where we spent our school life, or...
The Yokohama South area.
Yes, and Shimokitazawa in Tokyo.
They also go to Enoshima.
Right. They go to Kamakura as well.
Those depictions of the areas that are very
familiar to us were really fun to see.
The background animation was very realistic.
The characters have our last names, but I
don't think they have our personalities.
Yama-chan's character is
kind of a cool character.
Is that so?
My character is super outgoing.
We're talking about the character, not you.
He looked like he got complimented.
We're not complimenting you.
Yamada-san in the show is
a cool character, got it.
But maybe, the author of the
series has those images of us?
I don't think there's any correlation.
"Are you aware that many metal core
bands are influenced by "Haruka Kanata"?
Many well-known international bands
such as Bad Omens, Alpha Wolf,
and Archetypes Collide give "Haruka
Kanata" as one of the reasons
why they started making heavy metal music."
That's so cool.
Bad Omens is a very famous band, isn't it?
Sorry, I don't know.
I believe they're really famous,
and their music is on the heavy side.
I think they're kind of like
My Chemical Romance.
But in the past, we once heard that
"Haruka Kanata" was one of the...
Thundercat said he used to listen to it?
Right?
I know that "Haruka Kanata" was
in Thundercat's playlist.
That was a surprise.
I've heard stories like that
in the last several years,
and it was surprising that those who play
hard music like that like our song.
I mean, it makes us happy to hear
about fans, musicians or not.
If they like our song and it inspired
them to make something new.
Yeah, totally happy.
But we don't really think of our
music as metal, so it's unexpected.
But that's the interesting
thing about music.
Perhaps Yama-chan's heavy bass line in the
beginning might have something in common.
In terms of the sound.
That makes us happy.
Our album, "Surf Bungaku Kamakura,"
which we made in 2008, is making a
come back as a complete version.
There's a train line in Japan
called the Enoshima Electric Railway.
And it has 15 train stations.
Out of those 15, we made ten songs in 2008.
And we're making five more songs
for the rest of the stations,
We released an album "Surf Bungaku Kamakura Complete" in the summer of 2023 that is now available for streaming.
and the album featuring a total of
15 tracks is coming out this summer.
We released an album "Surf Bungaku Kamakura Complete" in the summer of 2023 that is now available for streaming.
So we hope you listen to it on
various streaming services.
We released an album "Surf Bungaku Kamakura Complete" in the summer of 2023 that is now available for streaming.
It's a power pop album
reminiscent of Weezer.
That's true. So if you're a fan of 90's
American alternative rock, you'll like this one.
Lots of homages throughout the
album, so please give it a listen.
From here, we're supposed to answer
questions individually in one sentence.
Let's start with Kiyoshi
and go down the line.
Are you ready?
"What is the first song on
your favorite playlist?"
Metallica's "72 Seasons."
The Lemon Twigs' "Any Time of Day."
I listen to that a lot, although it's
not the first song on my playlist.
You, Gotch-san?
Anohni's "It Must Change."
Everyone has one.
For me, Foo Fighters' "Under
You" is in my favorite playlist.
"Is there an artist or song
that you're secretly into?"
I like Cory Wong these days.
He comes to Fuji Rock.
Yama-san, how about you?
There's an artist called Beabadoobee.
She was at Summer Sonic, but we were on
a different day, so I couldn't see her.
But I've been wanting to go to her concert.
Coincidentally, my choice
is also Beabadoobee.
I like her recent songs.
Her slow songs, especially, are super good.
I'm blown away.
She's great.
The best.
For me, since we are making a power pop
album, I'm listening to Teenage Fanclub.
You're revisiting them?
I am. It's awesome.
"Is there music you listen
to while you cook?"
That question is for Kiyoshi.
He is the cook in our group.
I want it to be something fast tempo
to work quickly, so Andrew W.K..
Nostalgic choice.
And you, Yama-san? I hear you cook recently.
I don't listen to anything while cooking.
Tell us what you want to
listen to while cooking.
If I'm cooking, then "Surf
Bungaku Kamakura", I guess.
Our album, okay.
And you, Gotch-san?
No music while cooking for me, but I
suppose I listen to myself humming.
Same here.
I rarely cook, but at home,
I find myself humming a lot.
Right?
As I listen to the demo tape Gotch sent me,
I hum along and try to think
of guitar phrases and such.
I think I do that a lot at home.
Unconsciously.
"Do you have a favorite anime series?"
I have a lot of anime series I love...
What comes to mind?
But in my generation, it'd be Dragon
Ball. More than any other titles.
Yama-chan?
The first series of Mobile Suit Gundam.
You are obsessed with the first series.
How about you, Gotch?
I don't think international
anime fans know this,
even anime nerds might not know this
title, but mine is Uchuusen Sagittarius.
Uchuusen Sagittarius?
That takes me back.
Was it aired nationally in Japan?
Yes, it was.
I've never heard of it.
Yup, it was.
Wasn't it only in Shizuoka?
The theme song is amazing.
The theme song?
It's the ED called "Yume
Kounen," and it's crazy good.
Gotch and I sometimes sing it together.
It's the ED called "Yume
Kounen," and it's crazy good.
Gotch and I sometimes sing it together.
Maybe we can try and find it on YouTube?
Oh yeah, definitely.
For real?
"Yume Kounen" from Uchuusen
Sagittarius. It's really amazing.
As for me, I was a big fan of
Captain Tsubasa when I was little.
I used to play soccer because of that
show. I gave up on soccer though.
"If you could collaborate with any artist
you'd like, who would you pick?"
Kiyoshi, anyone in mind?
I'd have to say Dave Grohl.
From Foo Fighters.
I'd like him to produce us.
That would be cool.
That's be WurtS.
A young Japanese artist.
I'd love to work with him.
It might actually come true.
Gotch, anyone?
This is a pipe dream now since
it's not possible anymore.
Sure.
This is a pipe dream now since
it's not possible anymore.
And this is one of the things I regret.
Mr. Ryuichi Sakamoto passed away,
and I'd say we were rather close,
but we never got to create music together.
Together with him.
I've sampled his music and
created a rap track using that,
but I wish we could have
done a collab together.
I would have loved to listen to it.
If anything is possible,
then that would be my wish.
I can't think of an artist
I want to collaborate with,
but there are recording
studios I'm interested in.
At a farm in Wales, there's a
studio called Rockfield Studios.
I'd love to go.
At a farm in Wales, there's a
studio called Rockfield Studios.
And I'd love to visit there sometime, and do
recording there as ASIAN KUNG-FU GENERATION.
I'd love to go.
And I'd love to visit there sometime, and do
recording there as ASIAN KUNG-FU GENERATION.
Last question: "Is there a routine
that you do before a live concert?"
Personal routines are fine.
Personal routines?
But as a group, we do this.
Then Gotch puts his fist through here,
and I put my hand over it like this.
This is our pre-concert routine, and
Gotch makes a speech for the day.
A word from me.
He makes a speech.
My personal routine is...
I go to the bathroom.
Give us one more!
Can that be called a routine?
Everyone does that.
What do you do?
I guess I wear perfume.
That helps you relax?
I don't know if it's for relaxing, but
it's called "the high potential oil."
"High potential oil"?
Sounds sketchy.
Allows me to bring my high
potential during the show.
I think you made everyone in
the world laugh just now.
High potential oil.
What a name.
Okay. And you, Yama-chan?
Let's see, I never go on
stage without my wristbands.
Ah, yes. You do wear
wristbands all the time.
And your power stones.
It makes me uneasy if I'm not
wearing something on my wrists.
Makes you nervous?
And you, Gotch?
I do stretching.
Oh yeah, I see you roll out a yoga mat
and stretch in the dressing room.
As for me, I don't know if it's working
or not, but I drink an energy drink.
And I trust that it's working
and go do my best on stage.
Here are some questions about us.
So we point to whoever fits the answer.
Are you ready?
"Who is not a morning person?"
Three, two, one!
You're the only one pointing someone else.
But I wonder who it actually is.
Ken-san is on time these days.
I know, it used to be me
who was late all the time.
Ken-san is on time these days.
I know, it used to be me
who was late all the time.
But in the last few years, I stopped
drinking, so I tend to get up early.
You're on time these days.
Right, I'm not late anymore.
Aren't you proud of me?
So you were pointing at yourselves.
I'm not good with waking up early.
But my impression of you
is you're an early riser.
I don't like it, though.
You're forcing yourself to?
Trying hard.
And Kiyoshi?
Recently my tardiness stands out because
you aren't late anymore, Ken-san.
So it's become noticeable that
I'm the last one to arrive.
That's true.
Gotch, you are an early riser.
I can't stay asleep because I'm an old man.
"Who doesn't let the concert end?"
I wonder what it means?
Who keeps playing and doesn't
end the concert, I guess?
Not sure what it means.
Well, including what it means,
let's point our fingers.
Three, two, one!
Me?
Yama-chan, you're pointing at me?
Ken-san, you're the last one to join
us in the line at the end of a show.
Oh, that's true.
Ken-san, you're the last one to join
us in the line at the end of a show.
Oh, that's true.
When we bow at the end.
When we play as the headliner
at a festival and such,
we take a bow at the front of the stage,
but I'm the last one to join in the line.
I'm kind of taking it all in...
Yes, the last phrase of the last song.
The last song.
So maybe it is me.
But it's not like you're
doing something special.
So maybe it is me.
But it's not like you're
doing something special.
You're not doing it for the audience.
You're just enjoying the moment.
Yeah, exactly.
I just want to play an
arpeggio from the last note.
It reminds me of Ed from Radiohead.
He's still playing...
Still playing.
True, I stay on until the end.
Next up, "Who tends to forget the music?"
That's a tough question.
Three, two, one!
Oh, it's unanimous.
It's Kiyoshi. How do you feel about it?
It's not like I forget the music, but
I change it, like I can't help it.
I totally get that.
It's not like I forget the music, but
I change it, like I can't help it.
You did say that you can't repeat
the same thing over and over again.
Right.
I think I forget the most in
terms of how often I skip ahead.
Like the lyrics?
Yeah.
Yes, during a live performance...
I finish singing the song when it's not done.
Or skip to the second verse.
Exactly.
Or skip to the chorus too early.
Kiyoshi changing the phrase won't
lead to a critical problem.
With the drums, it's recoverable.
But the lyrics...
We're all like, "What do we
do?" when Gotch skips ahead.
A tense moment.
I've started singing in the
middle of the interlude.
With something like that,
we can adjust accordingly.
But that kind of stuff makes
the rest of us nervous.
In that sense, I make more
mistakes than anyone.
Moving on. "Who's the foodie in the band?"
A foodie? Who is it?
Let's do it.
Three, two, one!
Two votes for Yama-chan, two for me...?
Yama-chan, who are you pointing?
Yama-chan's vote on Gotch, got it.
You think Gotch is the foodie?
I don't know, but recently I hear him
say he wants to eat this and that.
I think Gotch is often very
clear on what he wants to eat.
You don't think so?
I don't know, maybe?
I just say it out loud when I
have a taste for something.
But out of all of us, you're a light eater.
Your eyes want to eat, not your stomach.
Okay, let's move on because I
don't need to talk about it.
I wanted to expand on this.
It'll get cut anyhow, I'm sure.
"Who finds new genres of music?"
This is easy.
Three, two, one!
This is Gotch.
Thank you.
You mentioned this earlier, but you listen
to different music from many countries.
I also have opportunities to
listen to many young Japanese artists.
You are versed in young artists too.
You're doing things to support
young Japanese musicians too.
That's true. I hope to continue doing that,
to make sure that new talents get discovered.
As for international music, we
each have our own specialty.
You know how at the end of the year, we
share the list of our favorites for that year?
Yes.
I've made new discoveries from doing that.
We get to learn new things from it, like what
kind of music the other members are listening to.
Exactly.
Like how I didn't know some of the
seasoned artists had new songs out.
I listen to big names in music often.
Like how I didn't know some of the
seasoned artists had new songs out.
I listen to big names in music often.
I enjoy that exchange.
Next up, "Who is the best dancer?"
That's a tough question.
Dancer?
Is there one? I don't think so.
Three, two, one!
Two votes for Yama-chan.
As in, sarcastically speaking?
I was thinking about the MV
for "A Flower Named You."
So sarcastically.
Gotch did dance in "Clicking
My Heels to Love."
Oh yes!
Yes, you did dance in "Clicking
My Heels to Love."
It was rough to remember the choreography.
You learned it overnight, right?
Overnight... yes.
I got the choreography at like 3 AM, and memorized it by the morning.
So in a few hours.
But I see you dancing
during our live concerts.
I'd like to learn how
to dance, like hip-hop.
I admire dancers.
Might be a good idea for a
vocalist to know how to dance.
Here's the last question:
"Who likes to pull pranks?"
Who likes to pull pranks?
I don't know...
Ready? Three, two, one!
Are you pointing at yourself, Gotch?
I think it's me.
You do like pranks.
I do.
You doodle on our faces often these days.
On our artist photos and materials.
I can't help but laugh when I catch
the sight of it during an interview.
I know.
He doodles in the middle of an interview.
It makes us nervous.
Exactly.
Another prank I pulled often was, at the
end of a live concert for an encore,
Yama-chan got excited
and ran out there first,
but then the rest of us
stopped and didn't go out.
Leaving him out alone on stage...
Just Yama-chan.
And I didn't even notice.
Right. That was fun.
Yama-chan's usually quiet, but during
live concerts, he gets a bit bossy.
Maybe he has the high potential oil on?
Yes, like the high potential oil.
To get himself hyped up.
That makes me want to let
him do his own thing.
You may pull little pranks like that.
Indeed.
Okay.
Thank you for watching, we're
ASIAN KUNG-FU GENERATION!
Thank you!
Thank you for watching, we're
ASIAN KUNG-FU GENERATION!